we all get um gifts uh
we get certain things in our life that
are um
that we're very lucky about and one of
the most powerful one is
the famous 80 20 rule where you know you
get 80 of the benefit by doing 20
of the work uh but you can't just
80 20 everything no one had ever heard
of an iphone
or an ipod before i mean the kardashians
were
in like the fifth grade wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one push through difficult times with
oprah winfrey
i went through some tough times after
after i left the oprah show i made a
conscious decision
that i did not want to be sitting on tv
with the oprah show and y'all saying she
should have left that show
that show was really good two years ago
i made a conscious decision decision
that when i felt i had said
all that i could say and the audience
had heard it that i would move on
and that i would not spend my life
regretting or trying to hold on to what
used to be or hold on to what i had
so i dreamed this dream of starting a
network
and in the beginning it was it was a
struggle
it was a struggle because i didn't
honestly the goodness i did not know
what i was doing
i was trying to figure it out i was
trying to figure it out
i thought that the oprah show audience
would follow us to own and then i
realized y'all didn't have cable
and if you had cable you did not have
the own package
[Applause]
so so it took me a minute and
unlike most people who you get to have
your mistakes in private
some don't go right in your life you get
to soak about it in private
if i make a mistake it's on the cnn
crawl
or the cnn news so when i was in the
climb and there were so many wonderful
owners i see churro action jackson here
there were so many wonderful owners
people who said oh we're gonna stand
with you we're gonna stand by you thank
you roland martin there were so many
people who said
listen we believe that this can happen
so i dreamed the dream
along with tyler perry who was my friend
who came to me and said tyler
[Applause]
tyler said i'm going to help you out
because tyler can go home and write a
script
and direct it produce it and shoot it
and do it for less money than anybody in
hollywood so we started with the
foundation
of having have not
if loving you is wrong
love thy neighbor mama hattie
and then i started to dream another
dream about
scripted television because in the
beginning i was told you couldn't do it
you couldn't do it didn't have enough
money to do it
and i dreamed the dream
i read proverbs 11 28 that says those
who trust in their riches will fall
but the righteous will rise and thrive
like a green leaf rule number two have
good role models with jeff bezos
we all get um gifts uh
we get certain things in our life that
are um
that we're very lucky about and one of
the most powerful one is who your early
role models are
you know you could they could be it was
your grandfather it was in a big sense
my mom and dad but my grandfather too
and you know i had my mom had me when
she was
uh 17 years old and she was still in
high school
in albuquerque new mexico and this is in
1964. i can assure you that
being a pregnant uh teenager in high
school was not
cool in albuquerque new mexico at that
time
and uh so uh it's in
in so it was a very it was difficult for
her
my grandfather went to bat for her when
they tried to kick her out of school and
you know
he they're they're incredible i had so
the gift
i had is i had this incredible family
rule number three
be driven with elon musk is the secret
to your success
to be the ceo of two companies at the
same time no
i think it's just look at the
correlation yeah struggling companies
everything's in the craft can in
december 2008. so let's take on a new
ceo gig
yeah and same for steve coming back to
alpha no it definitely was not my
intention to be co2 companies
um the uh i mean after
i mean i i there are certain things that
i kind of wanted to
i thought were important to happen and i
thought it was important that
that there was that an electric vehicle
happened that there was a success in the
electric vehicle arena
because the the incumbent companies were
convinced that it was not possible to
create a an electric car that looked
good had
rain a good range performance and so
forth um
and that even if you did make such a car
it would not sell
at because people had this love of
gasoline
and so we had to show that
it was possible to create a compelling
electric car
long range good looking you know all
those things that was a tesla roadster
and if you created if if you made such a
thing people would buy it
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and learn from billionaires
check out my 254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below if you're doing anything
interesting in the world
you're going to have critics the only
way if you absolutely can't tolerate
critics that don't do anything new
or interesting i wished i could it's the
one thing i wish i could do but i think
it's a gift
to be able to sing and that's not what i
was given but
since i was given so many others i'm
here today to prove to you in two words
there's no such thing as a bad idea and
that's footless pantyhose
rule number four don't 80 20 everything
with mark zuckerberg
when you first launched in the very
beginning the features were sort of
profile with like a profile photo in
your name and who you are
and also you included things like what
house you lived in
um what dorm you lived in um and what
courses you were taking
do you think it would have worked
without that would it have been enough
just to have profiles
you know it's a really interesting
question and we certainly since then
have evolved and wanted to make a more
general service so we've
so we've dropped some of those things
but i remember there's this early
debate that dustin and i had where
we had to do some manual work for every
school that we that we released facebook
ad
and um in order to do that we basically
went through and we parsed the course
catalogs of the schools to make sure
that the data was clean
and um and i remember having this debate
where dustin was like we could just
expand so much faster
or it would just be easier i mean we
were bound by server capacity
but it would be easier to launch new
schools if
we didn't have to have course catalogs
for each school and we just had this
really long debate about what quality
meant for us and the the community that
we wanted to establish and
and the culture of it and um you know in
retrospect you know maybe it wouldn't
have had a
huge difference on on how things played
out but it definitely kind of set this
tone where
there's a lot of kind of clean data on
facebook
you can rely on it it feels like a
college specific thing
yeah which was valuable early on for
setting the culture even though
obviously since then we've grown beyond
that
and you know i mean i think you guys in
the projects that you work on you're
gonna have a lot of
similar questions right i mean there's
the famous 80 20 rule where you know you
get 80
of the benefit by doing 20 of the work
uh but
you can't just 80 20 everything right i
mean there have to be certain things
that you just are the best at right and
that you go way further than anyone else
had to establish
this kind of quality bar and have your
product be the best thing that's out
there so
you know whether we had to do that one
or had to do something we had to do i
think enough of those things or else we
just wouldn't have been the best service
out there
rule number five have self-awareness
with mark cuban
you've never been shy to speak up in
issues that are important to you and one
of those themes
i've found has been around fairness and
whether that's
you know calling out referees for not
calling games consistently
or you know calling out a shark tank
contestant because you think that
they're scamming their customers
how do you decide what you're going to
speak up on or do you hold inside
you know it's changed over the years um
because i have kids
because social media you know twitter in
particular is so much different
um and it's changed kind of the rules of
engagement
um it's changed because of what i went
through with the mavericks last year i
missed a
sexual harassment problem that we had
because i wasn't i took my eye off the
ball
um and so you know i try to be
self-aware
and try to put myself in the shoes of
the person or people
or organization i'm talking about
whether it
adds value um i try to put myself in the
position
my own position you know how's it going
to be perceived
and you know is it worth it you know
will it create more good than
challenges and and so you've got to pick
your spots
rule number six be resourceful with
sarah blakely when spanx started i got
to set the stage a little bit for you
there were no self there were no
excuse me blackberries no one had ever
heard of an iphone or an ipod before
i mean the kardashians were in like the
fifth grade
and mapquest was just getting started so
half the time i was on my the computer
in the hotel that i was staying at and
trying to map quest my next location and
it was a really crazy time as i'm
driving all around
i you know i'm thinking to myself
actually i i remember this one time in
chicago i'd spent so much time alone on
the road
i did an event at the neiman marcus
outside of evanston i believe it was at
in oakbrook or northbrook and i spent
the whole day
promoting lifting up my pant leg and
turning and shaking my butt for everyone
in the entrance and that's
you know i'd been setting up these
tables and moving them farther and
farther out of the hosier department to
the point where they were in the
entrance of neiman marcus i mean people
would walk and i go hi
i'm sarah and i would flash them my butt
and you know i was trying everything i
put donuts on the table i was like have
a donut and some spanx
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is don't let adversity stop you with
jackman
foreign
[Music]
now i've got a special bonus tip from
john paul de jouria on how to pay
attention to the vital few that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know
what is the adversity that you will not
let
stop you let me know put it down in the
comments below and if you made it this
far in a video you're still here
watching i want to celebrate you because
believe nation we don't just watch
videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you if i had
email i would be inundated i
choose not to have email or ever turn a
computer on
now all my companies are state of the
art
technologically advanced if i want
something printed out it's printed out
for me
but i do this out of choice i'd rather
make a phone call to you
or write you a letter and communicate
the way you deserve to be communicated
with
and no disrespect to people on email and
i'd be so inundated my gosh i'd be on my
computer all day long
i prefer to have that personal touch and
it seems to work
with all the companies i have that i'm
quite active in but i have great
presence running
most of them thank god a very blessed
error right to take care of the details
but i'm still hands on in
many many of the businesses here and
it's i can work better that way
and it goes down to this pay attention
to the vital few
ignore the trivia many if i had email no
disrespect there'll be a lot of trivia
on there i'd be answering
i try and pay attention to the vital few
and ignore the trivia
what do you differentiate those those
two categories to being like where would
let's say your president be and where
would like the head of a sales division
be
are they on two sides of that equation
no what it is is if it's one of my
companies
you could call me directly but people
know call me directly if you have to
but don't bother me with something
someone else can handle they do it works
really really fine works really well
but what's important would be obviously
presence of company anyone that's
involved with me
either philanthropically the main people
philanthropically are the main people in
my businesses
or places or countries i want to reach
out to the head of a country will call
me
i'll call them right back you know
things have to be very significant
insignificant r i'll give you an example
in my life it has been significant
i'm hit up every month for hundreds of
requests
send me a hundred dollars send me two
million dollars you have all the money
share it with me and i just i don't even
touch it i can't i'm i'm swarmed
i do so much philanthropy now everyone
expects that whether it's a two million
dollar mortgage or hey i want to start a
new business send me 50 000
because you have money i don't that
people should do well that's not true
i spend millions on philanthropic work
but i do it through our foundation where
it really makes sense not where i have
to go through it all myself
[Music]
if you want even more advice from
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there in the business of technology
you have to think about what are you
missing what is the research or customer
feedback that you should be paying more
attention
to